*Loud noise*
Hey Jimmy!
Sorry, I'm just having a bite of my sandwich.
No, no, it's all good. How you been?
When, like, for the last decade?
- Yeah, it's a lot. - I know. It's a...
I think it may be close to at least
10 years if not the full 14 to graduate.
We'll see you graduated from college.
2012.
Okay, yeah, that's more than 10 years, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, like.
life has been pretty good. I mean, mine is probably
more in one place.
same family, all that kind of stuff.
stuff, just older and grayer and.
maybe a little more experience than I was.
years ago. How about you? Catch me up on...
on the narrative of the
big stuff before we get to this most stuff. Sure yeah.
Yeah, I am. So Nikki and I got married.
in 2016. I did. And...
- Go Mary, go Mary, I hope.
So married, yes.
We have
Two girls, we have Charlie and Billy, Charlie.
Billy will be 6 in April and Billy will be 4 in April.
in July. That's really big stuff. Six and
before you said?
Yeah, about to be.
Yes.
- Yes.
- Hmm.
- Yeah.
Yeah, and so we kind of...
We lived in a lot of different places.
Shortly after we got married, we moved to DC.
because Nikki got a fellowship.
On Capitol Hill, we lived there for three years, and that's
And when she got pregnant, we moved to Austin.
in Texas so that we could afford a
house. Austin, that doesn't sound
like an affordable place to live.
We lived in the--
a suburb outside of Austin that at the
The end of 2019 was more affordable.
And then we had Charlie and on April.
first of 2020 and you know what happened.
that time. So yeah.
And then we stayed down there until early 20.
2023 when we just had a heart.
time. We had enough of not being your family.
anymore. So we moved back up to
now just outside of Philadelphia in South Jersey.
That's where my family has all congregated at this.
point. Where is that around?
I mean, I was in Haverford before I came here, so I know that...
the Philly suburbs a little bit, but just on the penalties.
So yeah, it's a problem.
Awesome, I'm glad that is calling.
And it's working out and
to healthy kids. That's that's that's and ask for much more than
right? Yeah.
Yeah.
So my kids are 23 and 26 now.
And they are adults kind of.
I should say like here's here's the photo on my desk and that's even a few years.
years ago.
And they want, I'll eat my younger is a...
graduate from college, you know, you're
go June. He's working at a land trust.
up in Maine, where you went to college.
doing kind of land bank work.
Griffin my older 26 he's he was
He was an engineer, environmental engineer,
and now he's going back to...
to get his master's degree at State University.
University of New York Environmental Science up in Syracuse.
more work on a kind of more field-based work in
soil and composting and other kinds of things.
kinds of engineering that relate to that.
kind of stuff. So they're doing great, they're thriving and they're
not living in my house, which is good and bad,
like we missed.
them but they should be off on their own, shouldn't they?
Thanks.
And.
I don't know why.
She's had some rural health issues.
And two are.
attacks to retinue attachments.
But...
But otherwise, I just sort of...
screwed up her career a little bit so she's not working anymore.
She kind of left when I got the fellowship.
to go to Africa for a year.
I came along, did some writing projects.
And so now she's working part time over in the.
School of um, um, actually.
agriculture and she's writing a play about.
Her whole experience with elder care of her parents, which is
What gave her a heart attack into it?
But otherwise, you do it okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
(muffled talking)
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Yeah, that was our big light.
When I got sort of...
like both post COVID and post and
just because I've been doing the same thing for a long time.
I was like, I need something to shape this.
up. And that was our kind of shake it up mode.
try something really different.
not just stay steady.
as Red's director and professor and parent.
which were the big things.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
I mean, I don't think I'm gonna
leave Yukon. I mean, if I was gonna do that, I've had some opportunity.
needs to do that, but it doesn't make much.
sense for me at this point geographically or.
For us, unless we find the perfect
sort of seaside place, you know, once once once.
let Jill live on the beach, which she would love to do.
I think that can make it work.
But--
So the big career wise thing for me is...
how long stay with the writing center.
'Cause it's not.
really healthy to have somebody in the same directorship job.
for 20 years, which is decision.
Kathleen is rotated out back to regular faculty.
position and that's a very important thing.
I'll do that at some point too.
Yeah, but I'm still enjoying teaching.
We've developed a lot more.
The course has been on in literature, but that aren't writing.
And so I really don't teach a course like
Introduction to Writing Studies.
anymore. We're our first time you to think to my
in the course.
I need to get a little bit of water.
I got something.
So we've developed like a lot of things.
There's a lot more courses in writing.
Like this course called Introduction to Writings.
studies, writing rhetoric in the environments.
And so I'm teaching those kinds of writing in a...
I think along those lines more than literature courses kind of by choice
always, and we just writing minor.
And I've just done more of this international writing center work.
So, the kinds of things I'm teaching and the kinds of things.
the research I'm doing have changed. And that's, that's
the kind of gift of this kind of job where you can.
Say, "Okay, I'm going to work on religion and writing for a few."
years and then I'm going to pivot for thinking more about.
working in the STEM and the sciences, which I'd like to ask.
few years. And now I'm saying, well, I think I'm going to work more on
international context in Africa because they're underdeveloped.
writing programs and I have contacts now.
then something smacks you in the face like AI and you're like
Alright, I have to think about this anyway. It may as well do some research and writing on it.
on it. So that's kind of where my
sort of neighborhood of interests are.
writing centers getting moved around a little bit in ways that are
crimping me a little bit and not giving me a little freedom.
I'm kind of like, yeah.
I'll do this job as long as...
I enjoy it and as long as
I can run the writing sound of the way I want to.
you know, sort of valuing the things that that.
We do.
Yeah.
[MUSIC]
Oh, sorry.
So when I first got here.
I reported directly to Provost's office.
the writing center which thank you so.
which says, you know, it's an important enterprise.
Then we got moved to...
I know it's called the Center for Excellence in Teaching and Learning.
which is also good because the person there just kind of...
and let me alone and protect the budget.
and was happy with all the things we do.
And then just last year we got moved something called.
student success, which is kind of new vice provost.
And they basically are kind of clustering us with other tutoring programs.
and not valuing as much some of the
things that I value, which is the research.
the grad student developments, the mentor.
They did just want like more like stupid.
support stuff like we always do.
more sort of like we need to see more data we need to.
We need to cluster you more with
the Q Center and the academic achievement center and and
It's not bad stuff. It's just folks who...
don't necessarily appreciate the fact.
faculty side of it and just see it as a kind of student services.
And whereas I've always sort of seen the writing center more as a kind of
laboratory. We do student services but we all
We also do research.
We do mentorship.
We do.
kind of engagement with the field.
And again, no one's saying they don't care about it.
those kinds of things explicitly, but they're saying...
You know, a bunch of times are tight. Why do you?
all these GAs, what are they really doing? It was like they're working!
trust me, you know. So that
kind of thing. And just who I'm reporting to, whereas before.
before it was just a sense of like,
Tom knows what he's doing.
Now there's a sense of...
I said, well, show me commencement.
I argue for everything.
years and I'm like I've always done more with last slide.
try to pinch us again. So that's where the frustration comes in. Just
Part of the way is just a little bit of faculty prickliness about.
people trying to do more management and oversight.
of a program that I think is working pretty well.
You know, and always has. So.
coming up with your job is that in this new.
enterprise and what you've done leading up to it.
'Cause I know you've had a few.
different pathways through which
which I've kind of known by job title a little bit just through
linked in, but I don't know what they really need.
Thanks for watching!
[inaudible]
Bye!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(mumbles)
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
and I'm not going to be a scientist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(upbeat music)
[inaudible]
and
Yeah.
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
(keyboard clicking)
[inaudible]
(muffled speaking)
(upbeat music)
[inaudible]
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(upbeat music)
[inaudible]
There's a whole research project called the Tudor Alumni Research Project.
project, which tries to trace.
the trajectory of people as they leave right.
writing centers and ask them five, 10, 15 years later, like.
What's still with you? You know from from this.
signature experience. You know, is it whether.
Parktime job in college, I was fine and you made some friends.
or what parts of the listening.
skills, the negotiations around just sort of.
difficult situations, the capacity to come.
kind of problem-solved word is sort of,
all the things that you--
know what happened in those one-on-one encounters.
It's done by writing center people, so it's in.
to have a little bit of confirmation bias in the direction of
of, yes, this job sticks with people, but that's what they, it was cross
institutional and it's not so active right now.
It made his splash maybe 15, 20 years ago.
when they did their first round of research.
are following people about four different writing centers.
But what--
But most did testify to this sense of no, this
job sticks with me. This is yeah, I'm not.
doing one-on-one coaching and writing although it sounds like you
you might be still doing something pretty close to that.
But where we're going to be.
they went, you know, some of them went, became academics, you know, and take that's
It's actually a big pathway now to people thinking about.
traveling through graduate school, especially if they do ready.
and rhetoric. A lot of them come through the writing center, but that's not my
people, right? They're out there as social workers.
or as business people or as high school teachers.
or is other kinds of places.
Yeah.
*unintelligible*
Okay.
(muffled speaking)
[inaudible]
Yeah.
I mean, in some way, it's a sense where we've always collected data.
in a very basic kind of way, you know, numbers of students who
come in, all that kind of stuff.
We're still using the same.
WC online system that you might remember.
I've had archive of 20 years of
that AI now is poised to analyze.
if we want to do that just like millions of words.
in terms of a narrative snapshot of each encounter.
but I would usually report up data that was--
related to traffic patterns of usage, things like that.
like that.
But so we're still--
We're still using that same system,
although we're doing a lot.
more online work.
that we have different monalities, we have different lengths of
session. So we've gotten much more nimble in terms of
of just access.
COVID, you couldn't get through COVID.
without doing that kind of thing.
So that was the biggest nudge.
or push, not more than a no.
And now...
But you kind of have its own kind of custom made database.
Bye.
a homegrown system called Nexus, which is basically
they're just trying to collect where students move around campus.
It's really built for advisors.
to have a one-stop place where you could look up to students' records.
but also see how many times they've been to us.
other advising centers or to the Q Center or to the writing center.
And, you know, if they've attended
workshops or they've been to so it's just a kind of.
swipe in system that's not everywhere on campus.
So it's not.
total surveillance but it's trying.
tracking in a way that has that field.
tracking we hope in their best interest, right?
And so...
We've avoided using that system.
or forever because I was always saying,
I want the writing center to be a bit of a--
walled garden and you know.
We're not doing like for
of protected counseling here, but at the same time, we still have some pride.
privacy concerns around just privacy and other things.
But now we're kind of...
can't say no to that system.
It's not a big evil Google system.
and we're something that's gonna just scrape data and so.
So I'm okay with it in the sense that it does actually allow
other kinds of research.
Like I didn't know how to do that.
When the first gen students are really coming to the writing center.
health report and we have a way to act.
aggregate that and we didn't really in the WC online system.
because it totally relied on people just self-reporting and sometimes it
don't do that.
So the next system just--
gathers all this stuff that's already in the
their registration data and things like that.
We're--
So that's the system that goes.
going forward, we're going to kind of be doing these two parallel things.
Thanks.
I'll get you more time.
I know we were scheduled for like 20 minutes.
So I'm okay till two o'clock, but I'm
I don't know if you are.
to the end of the day.
with you? Like three, three.
I see people in my office where we actually--
you know, you sort of have an oral exam based on
If I did it for introduction writing studies, you'd have to.
I would pick a sonnet like a new,
they would have to do it on the spot.
And it would be based.
Anyway, I did a--
it's a regular--
part of my teaching now but a bunch of them got canceled yesterday because of...
university closing for a nice storm.
I'm teaching up today. So, so I was hard to stop it right before two of
clock. But I, but I, um,
I can talk until then if you're game.
Yeah. Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
Let me...
Well, let me put one thing, and this might be not the kind of operations work you do.
do, but it might be.
Like one thing we've been terrible about.
about Apropos of like you and me not talking for a day.
decade is deliberately
record keeping and keeping track of alumni.
And that's partly just the fun race.
good about going back and asking people to buy in either with time or
money. But that's also part of...
It's not the kind of thing I'm good at as far as infrastructure.
sure because it's not what they teach you when you do your PhD in.
I want to have a good year every day.
year but I'm not thinking and I'm thinking 10 years ahead.
In terms of what questions are coming out of the way, but I'm not thinking.
about like boy really needs to create a good database of former tutors.
So that like this year I was going to
run a 20th year anniversary thing and invite everybody back.
And that kind of got scuttled because our program
assistant. Do you equivalent? Was Margie there when you were there? Margie?
She left and is working English for me now and she's been replaced.
as one Margaret. Margaret just got sick with
she's doing chemotherapy right now.
So I was like, you know.
I was like, it's just not the year to hold a big event because.
are main administrative person is struggling.
and we just can't pull it off.
But...
But even if I wanted to pull it off, I'm like, I don't have.
You know, you saw me just put the LinkedIn thing there.
You know, really, just like a community.
the company page after you've been around since 2005.
but maybe we should do that.
because before I just relied on lots of informal connections,
like I've meant.
a lot of folks I'm in touch with people here and there especially for
is more dynamic life, but there's no.
way to follow up with them. So, so I'd love a way to sort of create.
Either claw back.
20 years of sort of finding people and networking them.
So, again, informally, informally, communicate with each other.
And then when there is this sort of...
yearly thing where Yukon says chip in 20 bucks to the program.
care about most, that the writing center is represented.
like, you know.
Because that's part of what we might need to do.
be looking more for in terms of just a bad.
a pretty generous budget, but it's never, never increasing.
You know, showing some entrepreneurial.
kind of fundraising would be helpful.
So that's one thing. The other thing is...
thinking about advising our graduates.
as they leave who might have that.
and the same value that is going to find their way into different ways.
places who could use that lung that
that alumni network could also just simply be
about advising and counseling and co-hosting.
and and and doing all things that
works do, right? Like in a friendly way, because we have some
common shared values.
and affections. So those are the two things that we have.
Those are two I can think of.
I don't know if that's up the alley of the working.
I mean, the other.
The other thing I could think of is if you want to come talk to some classes.
This is about how writing works in the world.
I teach a class called Infraction of Writing Studies where we're reading.
sort of about this, you know what I mean?
about how the way you're taught to write in school,
which is basically.
for assessment of what you've read is not the way that
writing mostly works out in the world and there's plenty of research on this.
But having more people to come in and say,
Hey, my job doesn't have writer in the title.
That is--
spend 75% of my day at the keyboard, as you said.
You are.
Yeah. I was.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
and stop the issue of the next project.
[inaudible]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
(upbeat music)
Well, there would be
from a certain point onward.
I can't remember.
I mean, I'm trying to remember when exactly we implemented the--
writing center practical. I think that was early.
writing center practice. You've never stopped offering that.
as a requirement to work.
So I interestingly enough now.
we created a dual enrollment version of that for the high schools.
So, as of two years ago,
We're offering we're allowing certain high school teachers
who have come to our writing center conference over the years.
and develop their own peer writing centers,
they can--
be mentored by me and teach that same course.
and get that. So it's offered
now at stores at the regional campuses too.
And at only about six or seven high schools in Connecticut.
We're growing that network.
But that would be one thing on a--
that would be the one thing on a transcript.
[inaudible]
Yep.
Yep. Yep.
(upbeat music)
Yep.
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Right.
Yeah.
even the backstory to a pre-writing.
Center English Resource Center where I
I know people around town who work to the writing center.
center in the 80s, you know, that when it was five person operation.
just in that little basement office.
CLAS, which is now called.
And so, so, but and and and.
It's not like we don't have paper records and old stories.
spreadsheets of staff also.
You're right, much more sweeping, efficient way would be this.
register our suite and then supplement that.
with what we have in terms of analog and digital records.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ Inaudible ]
[unintelligible]
So, I'll see you next week.
[INAUDIBLE]
[ Pause ]
I like that a lot.
Yeah, so I can do part then go to
the registrar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[inaudible]
We were talking about being this.
It was just actually came up in a meeting today because students had long...
for all these snow days we've had lately.
I was like, what project?
we do and one of the ones that came up was like well since you did just create that.
LinkedIn. Maybe we need to go back and just buy go look at all
And start inviting people into that kind of just in the
that kind of slow.
But, you know, it's not an infinite number of people for just talking.
I mean, 20 years.
20 years.
staff lists, right? And just sort of reach out to them and...
You know someone like Kathleen
You know, I was always very kind of careful.
never to invite.
tutors to be Facebook friends. I was like, if they want to invite me.
me, that's great. I want to be the boss who
imposes upon them.
But Kathleen wasn't like that at all.
She's...
She's like way connected to people.
you know, in social media in ways that I wasn't a.
because I was just clumsy on social media, but also because I
I did feel like I should not take the initiative.
stuff as a supervisor.
And but now it you lose it like I'm not
worried about connecting with people now, they don't, they've no.
They're not beholden to me, but I can use Kathleen's net.
works too and she'd help out with this kind of stuff.
(upbeat music)
[INAUDIBLE]
(muffled speaking)
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[inaudible]
and virtual too.
like if you want to come up to Connecticut, we'd love to have you.
Mike Space for that. And if you're going to do that kind of...
thing, we should do it more formally with the whole department.
We sometimes have these career panels.
I was even thinking about something sort of quicker and easier.
which was like zooming into my class.
on occasional semesters or having when we have a staff.
meeting or like I'll still have like seniors.
sometimes I'll just have a meeting with the seniors at Writing Center and I'll say
like what we do to help you launch.
and saying both connecting to you,
but also if we build this network, that.
amplifies versions of you out there.
right? Yeah.
[inaudible]
really?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[inaudible]
I'm the one from my feet.
I should.
but I wish I had more recollect.
But you needed.
a nudge too it sounded like.
Yeah, no.
I don't need a clear matter, but I don't doubt it at all.
And the name--
The name has a certain resonance to it.
Cool.
[indistinct chatter]
Did he have a sense of...
of. Miss.
and, and yeah.
good.
Yeah, good.
Yeah, I think we get a lot of that. I mean, I think I think
I think there's a whole lot of good will out there.
And I end.
For me, I've invested more of it mentoring.
those students who I can mentor best, which is people
There's a decent family trip.
now of writing center people all around the country.
running writing centers, you know, who are mostly our former GA.
not so much in the race.
But those are the people I just know because they're in my way.
world, but we want to get the others in.
in our worlds. Yeah, I like that.
Yeah.
Hello.
There's a research project in here too for the research train me too.
You know, like this is something that we
creating a video project around this that
sort of talks about it.
Like I said, the alarm--
I'm not association to be interested in this kind of thing too.
So I would love to do this.
And if you have other ideas, 'cause like, I brought those to you, but...
You have expertise that I might not think about as far as--
So let's follow up and talk to you.
more about the things that you would like to do if if if if
These are like priorities for me, but sometimes I...
I don't know what should be a priority unless someone proposes it.
What would you send my guest to me?
Thank you too.
And I hope to see these look--
kids at some point, if just in a picture, if not in
real life. That sounds awesome.
I'm glad that you are making the most of Southern New Jersey.
and setting out on your own. It's courageous to
to to to to find your own place and let me know what I
I can do, you know, to--
this back to you too in terms of connecting you to people who might be good for your
your emerging venture.
Okay, all right, good. Thank you. Thank you so much.
reaching out. We're gonna talk more okay just just
Let me know when you're ready.
Okay.